uh well let me ask you then in the space
of geometry
i don't know how well you know eric
weinstein oh bro quite well
what are your thoughts about
his geometric community and the space of
ideas that he's playing with
on uh
in his proposal for theory of everything
well i i think that he has
he fundamentally has i think the same
problems that everybody
has had trying to do this and you know
they're various they're really versions
of the same problem that you try to um
you try to get unity by put putting
everything into some bigger structure so
he's
has has some other ones that that he
that are not so conventional that he's
trying to work with but um
he has that he has the same problem that
even if he can
if he can get a lot farther in terms of
having a really well-defined
well-understood clear picture of this
these lar these things he's working with
they're really kind of large
geometrical structures and many
dimensions many kinds and i just don't
see any way
he's going to have the same problem the
string leaders have how do you get back
down to
the structures of the standard model and
how do you um
yeah so i just
anyway
it's the same
and there's another interesting example
of some similar kind of thing is um
garrett liszy's
theory of everything again you know he's
there it's a little bit more specific
than eric's he's
working with this e8 but it um
again
i think all these things found her at
the same point that you don't
you know you create this unity but then
you have no
you don't actually have a good idea how
you're going to get back to the to the
actual
to get to the objects we're seeing how
are you going to you create these big
symmetries how are you going to break
them and and because because we don't
see those imageries in in the real world
and um so ultimately there would need to
be a simple
process
for collapsing it to four dimensions
you'd have to explain well yeah and i
forget in his case but it's not just
four dimensions it's also these um
these structures you see in the standard
model there's a you know there's certain
very small dimensional groups of
symmetry so called u1 su-2 and su-3 and
the problem with
and this has been the problem since the
beginning almost immediately after 1973
about a year later two years later
people started talking about grand
unified theories so you take
the u1 the su-2 and the su-3 and you put
them in together into this bigger
structure called su5 or so-10
but then
you're stuck with this problem that wait
a minute now how
why does the world not look why do i not
see
the these su5 symmetries in the world i
only see these and so
and and i think you know those id
the kind of thing that that that eric
and also in garrett and lots of people
try to do it they all kind of found her
in that same
in that same way that they don't have
they don't have a good answer to that
are there lessons ideas to be learned
from theories like that from gary leases
from eric's
um i don't know it depends i have to
confess i haven't looked that closely at
a
at uh at eric's i mean he explained to
this to me um personally uh a few times
i've looked a bit at his paper but it's
um
again we're we're back to the problem of
a limited amount of time in life and
yeah i mean it's an interesting effect
right
why don't more physicists look at it
there
i mean i i'm in this position that
somehow
you know
uh
i've i've uh
people write me emails for whatever
reason
and i'd work in the space of ai and so
there's a lot of people perhaps ai is
even way more accessible than physics in
a certain sense it's a lot of people
write to me with different theories
about they have for how to create uh
general intelligence
and it's again a little bit of an excuse
i say to myself like well i only have a
limited amount of time so that's why i'm
not investigating it but i wonder if um
there's ideas out there
that are still powerful they're still
fascinating and that i'm missing because
i'm
because i'm dismissing them
because they're outside of the sort of
the usual process of academic research
yeah well i mean the same thing in
pretty much every day in my email
there's a somebody's got a
theory of everything about why all of
what physicists are doing
perhaps the most disturbing thing i
should say about my uh critique being a
critic of string theory is is that when
you realize who your fans are um that
they
every day i hear from somebody said oh
well since you don't like string theory
you must of course agree with me that
this is the right way to think about
everything
oh no oh no
and you know
most of these
are you know you quickly you can see
this is person doesn't know very much
and doesn't know what they're doing you
know but there's a whole continuum to
you know people who are quite serious
physicists and mathematicians who are
making a fairly serious attempt to try
to to do something and like like eric
and uh and eric and then
then your your problem is
you know you spent you
you do so won't try to spend more time
looking at it and try to figure out what
they're really doing but
then at some point you just realize wait
a minute you know for me to really
really understand exactly what's going
on here would just
take
time i just don't have
yeah it takes a long time which is the
nice thing about ai
is
unlike the kind of physics we're talking
about
if your idea is good
that should
quite naturally lead to you being able
to build a system that's intelligent so
you don't need to get approval from
somebody that's saying you have a good
idea here you can just utilize that idea
and engineer a system like naturally
leads to engineering with physics here
if you have a
perfect theory that explains everything
that still doesn't obviously lead one to
um
to to scientific experiments that can
validate that theory and two to like uh
trinkets you can build and sell right
right and at a store for five dollars i
can't make money off of it
[Laughter]
so that that makes it much much more
challenging
you